like you do not need a mentor you need someone to grow with you right and like that that's
something that a lot of beginners uh have trouble with is that oh i need someone to learn from and
that's not the fact like you need someone to learn with yes in order to grow up together and
i think that's the best best part of hacking when you can just you know critical things right
okay like 30 seconds before we started recording just just say that again for the for the mic yeah
i i never watched the podcast so i don't know what we're going to talk about come on man you're
killing me i'm just kidding i'm just kidding of course um all right guys we're here we're in
japan yeah in akone that's awesome the live live hacking event is uh is a is a wrap and uh
yeah we've just been relaxing for the past couple i don't know if you'd call it maybe relaxing we've
been doing some pretty intense sightseeing the hiking was not relaxing yeah yeah um but yeah what did you
guys what did you guys think of the live hacking event any any lessons learned or takeaways we want
to we want to share man i i thought that the live event was uh really cool in tokyo and everything i
think like the lesson i learned is that how to pick fights you know uh that in a way that um there is
some bugs where you need to argue more than others and you do not have the time to argue on every
bugs right when you're on the live hacking event scene so uh you need to really pick like what are the
most impactful bugs and which one do you take time to explain to the program and which one do you just
kind of quit arguing about it so that was a good lesson i think yeah absolutely i mean some of the
some of the bugs that had come out of this event especially the things that were shown at show and
tell were some of the most unexpected things i'd say like yeah i was very surprised at like honestly a
lot of them were very like simple straightforward like definitely in hindsight i was like oh i should
have just yeah i'm surprised i didn't see that or you know whatever it is um and some of them were just
like insanely big brained like yeah um i don't i don't want to go into too many details but there
was one with like uh you would put like the same parameter in twice and i would just probably just
would have never even tried anything like that i i mean that like a lot of the bugs were um simple
technically but you needed to find how to do it and so this is like the frugality of uh bug bounty when
you find like something really easy to reproduce but at the same time you need to be really creative
about how you find those kind of bugs and so there is a lot of people that went the extra miles in the
recon because we had like a small scope and there was so much out of the box thinking and it's really
inspiring to see the show and tells yeah man that was that was the thing for me on this one i i have
a lot of i have a lot of takeaways from this one um it was it was a little bit of a challenging one
for me personally so uh i was sitting in the in the uh hot bath with uh with noggly last night kind of
uh you know running over what kind of stuff that we could have done differently and just like you guys
said you know there there were just a lot of bugs at this event that were just like wow um you you know
why would you even try that you know like and and uh so definitely thinking out of the box and then i
think another another really thing that became really clear to me this event was um you know the the team
made it very clear that like if you are able to impact core components in pii that they don't
they don't care like you know like you you that is what they want you know and so scope is not
not a problem at that point right as long as their users are getting protected um which i think is
really great but it's something that i didn't prioritize quite as well you know during this event
and and i think um the the hackers that that went around the scope and then found ways to uh you know
attack the core assets in in pii i think they did the best this this event that's really impressive
yeah yeah and i think one of the interesting things we actually talked about this like last
week on the last episode about where's sort of the ethical boundary about going out of scope and like
yes is it okay to go out of scope if it provides impact and i think one sort of caveat to this is it
wasn't really like out of scope per se it was it was more like out of scope for the event it would be in
scope for the main program and i think like worst case scenario if you'd really gone like out of
of scope out of scope they just moved to the main program but they were really looking for things
that would cause impact to this to this you know special scope that was being targeted and and just
in general to to the program as a whole and so i think it was really awesome that they were they
they said that was okay for you to you know sort of bend it a little bit as long as you're able to
provide impact because they have that awesome relationship with the researchers i think that every
company should do that uh when they have the maturity because um like i don't like scope in the sense of
domains right but i like scope about the sense of where you are impacting the data right so in my
opinion scope shouldn't be like uh there is this subdomain that is scope but the other one is not in
scope imagine that you have a subdomain that is exposed you do not even know about and there is
direct link to the database with a sequin injection this is the same database that is impacted with the
same data but it wouldn't be in scope and so i prefer when program says uh for instance the core database
is in scope but we do not care about the entry point right and there is other programs that are
really mature about third parties because uh european companies actually if there is a third party
leaking data or anything they are still responsible the first party is always responsible and um and so
it's really cool when you you can you know hunt on third parties also so i i really wish we had more
maturities in that realm you know yeah it's definitely it's definitely cool to see and i think
um you know like you said that's something that's a more mature program decision but it's really awesome
to see and it actually makes the most sense from a technical perspective too because like you run into
these programs where it's like okay this domain is in scope okay well what the heck does that mean
because nine times out of ten that domain is resolving to an ip that's a load balancer and that load
balancer serves many different applications so if you're saying okay this ip is in scope well then
i can uh modify the host header on that specific request and get routed to all sorts of different
applications for those in scope you know um and so it's cool to see a program you know like you said
take responsibility as the the first party um and and do that um the other the other big takeaway for
me from this event was um i guess very thoroughly at auditing javascript files that are not necessarily on
the main asset you know and um and for me one of the things that i i knew before this event and i
actually did but didn't thoroughly assess uh was lazy loaded uh webpack files right um interesting and so
uh you know going that extra mile to uh you know open up the core main.js file dump all of the uh you
know dynamically loaded javascript files that are also you know in that same folder grabbing all those down and
then making sure you're thoroughly auditing all those to get uh the api all the api resources you need
um you know that that was that would have made a big difference for me during this event yeah and like
it's it's it's very counterintuitive because if you're hacking on that app and you look at it in burp
you say you just go to a login page you're not going to see all of the other modules being loaded
because they're lazy loaded it's only going to load the things that are necessary and so if you just see
oh there's this js file and you just see only a couple little endpoints or whatever that and that's
it that you're you have to go you have to explicitly pull apart those those javascript files and you're
going to find the other functionality because it's in there you just have to go and get it and if you
don't log in or something so you'd say it's an admin portal right you can't log in well you might
not see those but they're there and if you go deeper you may actually be able to access things
within those files and you'll see the other functionality but it'll take more time and something like
and something like js weasel i think you know we've talked about this before you know tools like
like that are designed for analyzing javascript functionality those are really going to come into
play as more and more like react apps and that kind of stuff that are doing this type of behavior
come into play yeah yeah i think i found so many bugs that were so easy but just like hidden in some
javascript calls that were made by the front end because i didn't have the privilege or or anything and
also what's really interesting about the js files that there is a lot of calls that hasn't been
released in production yet so it's behind a b testing and so if you manage to detect those a b
tests you might end up with a new scope to play with like a wider attack surface and especially for
companies that do continuous development this is super true so if you manage to change the a b testing and
look at all the js files you might end up with really simple vulnerabilities like the basic eye door
but just because it was so hidden inside the the scope uh you no one found it so yeah definitely
interesting monitoring those monitoring those uh endpoints has always been you know the js files
and then like you said taking that extra layer that's always been on my to-do list for automation
you know soft core automation i guess is like okay um you know i'm really interested in this one
program i'm gonna set up an automation system specifically designed around their you know cycle their
their software development cycle and have that that pushed out um but yeah i was gonna ask as well
um regarding you mentioned a a when we were walking down the street to the to the freaking uh shrine
earlier today to meet up with friends um you know you mentioned that there was this vs code uh plugin
that that you've been using um and i imagine it actually would work well in conjunction with js weasel
exactly yeah yeah could you talk a little bit about that because that was a really interesting product
yeah so i i saw uh the tweet of corbin that basically used js weasel uh with cursor and cursor is
like a wrapper around vs code uh since vs code is mostly open source and basically they are embedding
uh gpt4 inside the vs code and you can directly ask questions about your code base what's really
interesting is that you can pay um the subscription but you can also directly natively use your gpt4
api key so you directly pay to open ai and no need to go through their servers okay and um it's so
amazing like uh right now i i'm using it to do uh javascript analysis on uh google that they use like a
lot of rpc weird calls like it's horrible proprietary protocol yeah and basically i'm going like okay that's the
edge point of the request right so what are the parameters because they are like so embedded in
one function to another function to another function and basically i just asking the ai um tell me which
other function you want context to so i can provide it to you and we can reconstruct the request and i did
that like maybe five six times and at one point i just got the request that i needed to send wow and
and like the protobuf request and i was like oh that's amazing and it just built it automatically
yeah wow and so i used js weasel to detect uh which like like all the endpoints you did some automation
also to get the ideas right and then you just ask cursor okay explain to me this code and this is the
job like instead of having like six to seven hours of code review you do it like maybe in two hours
it's so great i love it wow it's really interesting like i think this is something
before ai or like gpt was really yeah more you know before it was as as flushed out as it is this
would be something that you might have like code ql or maybe some more of a technical tool we doing but
this the approach is basically just feeding it into ai and saying hey what do i need to know about this
it's so much more powerful because it can do everything just like in an instant where it just
analyzes this huge chunk of data and is able to just parse it and tell you oh yeah here's what you need to
know i'm i'm a little i'm a little confused about how that works though because i feel like the code
base would extend past the context window any any do either of you guys know how that works or is it
with gpt4 like 8k or something i don't know um so uh basically when i use it i select the lines of code
i wanted to interpret uh but they natively use a way to uh compress the file and basically they have like
some kind of if i understood correctly a search engine on the client side that uh that depending on the
question will go look for the code before and then giving the context to open ai so you do not have to
give everything i see a bit like bing search is doing like the search engine uh does the first request
and then give the data back to open ai and open ai will uh put context i see i see yeah that's really
interesting because like what you meant we were talking earlier about like tokens and and sort of
how like ai looks at input as tokens and it splits it up into different segments that it can understand
better and sort of looks at those pieces individually and then we'll build like the context together and
i think that's like what you said like it the way that it parses that is kind of counter-intuitive
because you might think like oh you know i can't feed a giant file but you can because it it can do
some more processing magic on it than yeah before um i mean like llm are trained on so many data points
that actually they can complete context uh so if you say this function passes something they can guess
uh it's not like the the more accurate way to do it but i think the cursor team did a great job about
knowing what to feed to the ai and knowing like what they already know so you you can like compress
as much as possible the tokens to not you know pay the 8k subscription right right right um yeah and
i think combining those two tools together js weasel and and uh was it cursor cursor okay like mouse
cursor yeah okay gotcha gotcha um yeah combining those two tools together is a really powerful combo so
shout out to corbin for for that one um uh yeah i'm i'm definitely i'm definitely interested to see
where all that goes and js weasel uh i think we'll probably cover in a little bit more detail on a
different episode um but i i booted it up for the first time during this live hacking event and i've
been using it and uh it's really cool to see it do automatically what we talked about you know breaking
out those those um uh file web packed js files and having it you know drop all of the things there
um but i'm wondering i don't know if you've used it joel but for for you lupin um i'm wondering uh
how you've been using the tool because for me i've been having a little bit of a difficulty with and i
talked to charlie about this and i think he's fixing it but um i've been having a little bit of difficulty
with identifying the portions of the js code that i really want to analyze because there's not a search
function presently yeah um and so i mean do you do you have that same struggle have you worked around it
what how are you using the tool currently yeah um the the tool misses like a search uh function uh
yeah that that's definitely something uh that needs to be implemented um the way i use it is more about
like um knowing the attack surface and the constructing uh word list out of it so uh basically i had um
um this graphql uh um api uh that was um behind authentication and so it was just for admins right
but you could with a low privileged user just because uh you know cookies are where i can get
that you could make a simple request to it but without authorization of course and um the introspection
wasn't turned on okay so how do you know which queries do you do you go to the js files right
and what i did with jes weasel that was awesome it listed all the queries i just copied all the queries
and uh generated world lists that i gave to clairvoyance right uh and basically uh clairvoyance will try
to brute force the the schema the graphical schema and give it back to you and so then i fit this 70 mo
like it was a big schema uh to graphial viager and i had like everything every call that it was being
made because they like in when there is a graph here everything is always documented in the front end
i don't know why there is some libraries that even have introspection inside the js like if it's not
turned on go check the js and you can copy the introspection and paste it just because they forgot to
to turn a flag i've never seen that yeah i've seen like a lot of times and it's so interesting um so
so it's so funny you mention that because i literally did the exact same thing
i i except i didn't use js weasel for it i used my own parsing script to you know expand the web pack
files yeah and then i did exactly that i i took a regex i pulled every string that was compliant with uh
graphql um you know naming standards essentially for for queries and for um for field names and that
sort of thing and i put it all in a word list and i fed it to clairvoyance um and for those of you that
are listening that aren't familiar we'll link it down below but clairvoyance is a is a um is a tool that
uh i guess sort of plays on the problem with graphql where they will recommend you uh fields if you
have the improperly uh defined fields so uh you know let's say you there's a field called store and you
know sometimes it's even like like pretty pretty far like you might even get away with like sport and
it may be did you mean store yeah and they'll tell you it really depends on the back end uh so depending
on the language uh you you can set up uh the amount of token that needs to to be uh the same so really
oh interesting yeah so sometimes it's like two tokens apart so two letters sometimes it's three four
uh and they can set up that on the back end side and depending on the framework they will have a
different kind of uh far way or not you know yeah well i mean it's really interesting that you mentioned
that that that strategy with graphql because i was i was gonna say the same thing about not even just
graphql but same thing with api requests like if yes if you're pulling apart those webpack uh files
and the lazy loaded files not only will you see the endpoints but you also see how they're being
used where's that data coming from and one of the really powerful things about having all of that just
right in front of you in javascript it's just like android apps where you know you can decompile it
you can see how everything is working like right in front of you can do the same thing with the
javascript all you have to do is pull it apart you can see oh it's making a post request and it builds
the body with these fields that are named this and that data comes from here it's a parameter and
that's fed in through here and you can track it all and you can see sort of how that data flows
through the application to get to that request and you can piece it together without ever having
used the application at all you can do it completely from static analysis yeah yeah um cool all right
well but we went on a little bit of a tangent there um i told you so it's true it's true right before we
started you were like we're definitely gonna go on on this here so i i feel like we should at least
have you introduce yourself that's a good one okay listen listen listen listen i i turned i turned it
on you know at the time that i did on purpose um we'll we'll give you a little bit of a pre-introduction
on this episode but yeah let's let's let's hear the self-introduction or the jiko shokai uh for you
lupin um so what does she want to do this oh man uh yeah so i'm ronnie uh also known as lupin on
the internet uh i've been doing um security since uh 13 years old uh because i wanted to become like
arson lupin i knew a bit of programming and i was i read the book of arson lupin i was like how can i
become that guy at the moment i read the book and i made the association with programming i thought i
created the hacking but but then i learned about all the history all the culture from the 50s and
everything and i i love it so much i started yeah i was gonna say how's that got me are you looping i
feel like you're looping i feel like you've done that you know like i mean uh lupin is a gentleman
thief i i'm not stealing from anyone maybe stealing from companies that because they're giving booty i
don't know that's a stretch you're the top lupin that i'm aware of you know when i think lupin i think
you not anyone else thanks a lot and um and yeah so uh and i started bug bounty hunting like two years
and a half ago four years maybe i don't i don't remember correctly but um and it has been a wild
ride uh i started the live hacking scenes uh one year ago in vegas and uh it's just amazing uh of
experience it's awesome how did you how did you get on the live hacking event scene did you just get it
you just open your mail one day and there was an invite or um i think it was like the first
ambassador world cup uh because since i'm uh an ambassador for france and apparently i did well
i i don't think so uh but they gave me an invite uh to vegas uh we actually won the first world cup
even though the second one we didn't get the first one i think i did well they won
i didn't i didn't get out of the first round of the world cup either and it's just i don't know man
sometimes it's just you know i'm not i'm not even gonna throw any salt but it happens yeah it happens
no comment uh and yeah um live hacking uh way different the bug bounty uh it's so tiresome you
you get like one month uh straight of you know no social interaction anymore you know going to bed at
5 00 a.m starting your day at 10 00 a.m and you're like ah it's so interesting seeing how how things have
shifted in the very early days of live hacking events it used to be i mean sometimes you wouldn't
even know the scope until you got there yeah and uh and it would just be like hack fest everybody's
just like finding really cool bugs on the same day and now it's evolved so that there's like a
a pre-hacking window there's a duplication window people are basically you know work 12 hours a day
sometimes more definitely uh just every single day leading up to the event finding all these really
really crazy bugs and then they convene together and even more crazy bugs get found because of the
minds connecting together and having these awesome discussions between hackers amazing something that
jonathan said jonathan boomman uh dr bowman yeah dr bowman that i really liked is he said that he
wanted to have the show and tells before the event starts on site to inspire other people to find stuff
and i think it's an amazing idea so imagine you you two weeks you're down the rabbit hole you didn't
find anything and you have like people showing you for a bit like this is how we've done it and like
inspiring you into finding new stuff on site that could be so awesome oh yeah that would be that would
be amazing and we always walk away from those show and tells like you know your brains are just buzzing
you know and and you're like oh man maybe i could apply that here or there and then and then you
know you go out and you know hit the bar or whatever and then the next day you don't even check it but
yeah it uh that would be that would be a really good idea the last show and tells in vegas uh there
was france frozen that had two show and tells back to back and so salty i missed this yeah and uh and
man like i i went out of this show and tell with an headache uh like because of him it was just so many
stuff going on and i was like what the heck is he talking about and i i want to go back again reading
his reports let's get better at it right because trends are like this you get creativity from other
people and you you you don't need to do what they did but you need to apply what you learn for your
own creativity and i really like this format because of that yeah i mean oftentimes i'd say it's like
maybe 25 75 like you know one third like two thirds kind of split or whatever where i'll see a bug
and i'll be like oh i was looking at that thing i i almost thought about trying that or maybe i did
try it and i just didn't really push far enough and i was like i just tried it i was like okay
this isn't gonna work and i just moved on and then that ended up being a bug but so many other times
there'll be something completely out of left field where i'm like i never would have tried like never
ever would have tried anything like that and i sort of have to take mental notes and be like okay that's
something that i need to see if that's gonna work why did that work was it like a specific system was
it how it was set up what went wrong in the back end to make that happen there was um like my first
event in vegas there was a great show and tell from tom anthony and um the the the one in london
there was a customer that was the the same one and i remember like uh this feature i did i never hacked
on that customer like on the other event i hacked on the other customer uh but i remember he mentioned a
really interesting feature and so i went looking for that feature and i was like that's interesting
remember what he did and like i was remembering like the bug and everything and i found a bypass
like a simpler version but complex because like it was a lot of parsing requirements and stuff like
that so the payload was simpler but it was like so hard to find and basically because of his show and
tell i got like a bypass of one of his volubility for one year ago and it was like that's the purpose of
trying to like getting new visibility and new creativity you know yeah i think i think that's
something that we could think about implementing in the ambassador program as well the hacker one
ambassador program is like if we uh you you're the ambassador for france i'm the ambassador for uh
virginia um and i think it would be really cool after you know we go uh do a spree of hacking to
have a little show and tell you know for our locality or whatever that'd be really good and we'd
learn a little bit more uh you know from all the other hackers and stuff like that yeah um yeah
we'll have to have to think about implementing brainstorming session yeah okay okay so so um
i guess bringing it back uh lupin you recently started a company called lupin at homes yeah um
beautiful website lnh dot lnh dot tech yeah beautiful website everything lupin designs you know or has
designed is like super gorgeous um talk to me a little bit about that company what your goals are for the
the company how it relates to bug bounty that sort of thing um so it really started uh like before
finding this company i was a senior security engineer uh at mano mano so a european uh company
like marketplace online and uh i i entered that company when i was 18 years old uh i did like two
years there and i learned so much and i learned also like what the purpose of research in security and
how it can be applied uh to companies and from that learning i was like i need to do more uh research
in security right okay i'm gonna i'm gonna interrupt and then we're gonna come back to that so actually
you know you're you're at you said you're at mano mano you joined when you were 18. yeah and then you
left like when when i was 20 and 21 21 yeah and which is now yeah okay gotcha and and you what was your
title at mano mano uh senior security engineer okay gotcha wow so you see how the heck did an 18 year
old just jump right into big marketplace and get to be a secure how did that work like what was that
process so um basically i was never good at school i always hated it uh it's a good sign yeah it's a good
signer and uh but i i always wanted to do a creative job right and i i was hacking and and
someone introduced me to um back brunty right actually it was i like my teacher that told me hey
there's this ctf do you want to participate and yeah in high school yeah uh it was like a european ctf
the the cso uh for high schoolers uh from all around europe okay and i i brought like uh two
friends with me and i told them you do not have to play the ctf i just need people people from my
team to go there like to to put someone on the list and uh we we qualified to the finals and there was
uh all the conferences and stuff and there was a conference from yes we hack right and they they were
telling hey you can actually get paid for finding security vulnerabilities and i was like that's
legal that's awesome yeah i have a mind yeah and so i got back uh at home and i was like okay what
is back bounty and uh uh i stumbled across hack one and you could disclose vulnerabilities and that's
the only reason i went on so ironically yes we are gave me the idea to go on hack one yes
but uh yeah i really like the disclosure because actually you you could share vulnerabilities and you
could prove uh your experience right and so i started bug bounty hunting it was hard at the
beginning but because of the reputation and the fact that you have a public profile i use that as
my cv my resume and i showed companies that hey i actually managed to hack those big companies and uh i
have the technical skills right and you know i i don't do research there was stuff published in the
media i did some interviews in the television visibility also helps yeah and um all of that
like uh one day a friend of mine uh zax uh told me hey there is uh this company that will hire a
security engineer uh they didn't open the the job yet but i recommended you and like two days afterward i
got a ping and i they actually hired me before the job was open wow and uh actually based only off of
a recommendation or did you do an interview i did i did an interview i like i did several interviews
with the team they saw his work and they were like we need to hire this guy i did several interviews
they were great really funny interviews actually and uh jules that was uh my manager not the one that you
know but like uh he he was so great with me he's also really young at the time i think he was 24 and
he was my manager and i was his first employee and we had like a great relationship he helped me grow
and you know that led to research into creating my own company so basically my brother has like a similar
stories with studies uh he never uh like he did seven years of first years of college right seven
times yeah he like because he was bored of it and so he did like actually uh the first years of my
older brothers in low like in lowe's stuff and in philosophy and he never liked anything but my father
one day said hey you don't know anything about programming about development yeah you barely know
how to use a computer but there is like the 42 school uh network that opened like it was like
really new at the time in 2017 i think and uh he said uh to him go do that school and basically it's
a school without teachers okay uh and there is no courses like you just have exercises uh of programming
and you do not need to know programming to get into that school it's 100 free and the school is open 24 7.
wow so to get into that school you need to pass a logical test and then you have something called
the piscine which is the pool okay and the pool basically you have one month of intensive programming
where you need to learn from scratch to become like an expert in c and c plus plus oh wow okay which
is horrible horrible yeah and if you pass all the tests you get in the school okay right so it's
hardcore mode you need to try out and what's like what's sort of the incentive to to like pass
that test is there some sort of like is it very exclusive is there like a certain like once you're
there it helps you get a better job or why why would people want to push through that and learn c and
z plus plus and stuff in order to get there you learn so much in a condensed uh time so so in one
month you actually know how to program fully in c and c plus plus which is astonishing like what they
manage to do and in one year you can get a job for the like the the better students or otherwise in two
three years but you do not need any degrees and you will get hired by companies so that's the incentive
like you do not know what to do with your life go to that school if you like remotely computers yeah
and he actually did and he became like a good back-end developer like but like yeah really good and
um he he works for many different startups and you know we were talking and you know sharing knowledge
about you know our jobs and one time we're like i do research in security you do development we need
to do something yeah we need to do something together and so we wanted to create that r d company and
because my nickname was lupin we needed to find a nickname for him and like holmes was the perfect one
like sherlock yeah and it goes really good with him because uh i guess holmes used the deduction like
when you are programming you need to you know find the best path to create something yeah and
holmes is really like that and also my brother do do not like to talk in the medias i do not like the
fame he exactly like sherlock holmes they were like this is like the great persona for him right yeah and
so lupin and holmes is really about you know trying to complete one another we are opposite sides but
like oh the opposite of a coin right we we just yeah yeah they must be together but never at the same
time exactly and so i i use bug bounty as a way to do research and then everything that i learned from
bug bounty about you know maybe fixing vulnerabilities or finding the vulnerabilities i then ask my brother to
code tools and then those tools are going to be on products that we are going to sell to companies
maybe to bug hunters but mostly for companies so so you've got uh you know on that line you've got a
secret product that that we won't talk about on on this episode but we will be talking about on a future
episode and uh and your brother is is primarily doing the the coding for that yeah wow he's doing the entire
backend wow um and it it's it's pretty good because um sometimes i ask him to do something uh security
related and he's like why like why would anyone try that and i'm like that's the whole purpose of the
research exactly yeah yeah no that's that's great um yeah yeah the and so i guess how is it with you
then um working with somebody else's code because for me like especially within my automation framework
i feel like i need to know the ins and outs of it and even sometimes when i don't when i look at a
piece of code that i wrote like three years ago four years ago it's like you know who the frick wrote
this yeah you know before joel started influencing my python programming uh so i mean has that has that
worked all right for you i mean have you written any of the code yourself i've written some of the code
uh mostly for the clients uh but not uh for the backends um i think it's better if i do not touch the code
uh that's what he tells you at least yeah yeah definitely uh
yeah and uh it's more like we need to separate our jobs like my job is to actually find new ways to do
research and his job is to develop and it's actually good that i do not touch the code because
i'm doing like a bit of the product manager like i ask things that are not possible and he needs to
find a way to do them yeah i actually love that that sort of um that separation of roles where
normally you would say like research and development is sort of like globed into one thing where you know
you're doing research and you're developing but research and right like one of you is doing research
one of you is doing development and it sort of allows you to have a singular focus and
really hone in on that because one of the things that we've talked about is um you know there's the
xkcd right where it's about automation and it's you know over time all of your time starts to get
taken up by having to maintain and manage this system exactly and that is going to take away from
the amount of time that you have to do research and actually learn new things learn new techniques
and explore and find new bugs and that kind of stuff and so if you can separate that out and say here
you managed with the development all managed with the research that really allows each of you to sort
of hone in that craft to 100 percent i would take an example of a proof of concept that we are doing
right now uh basically there was like this target that is renowned for blind xss and i was like we
need to find a way to automate buying the xs but not in the way that do dumb automation about just you
know putting everything out there and just see what will happen but like you know try to find the right
payload for the right context and this is hard but i know that some hunters are really good at
understanding how the panel like admin panel size works right and they know the right payload to it
and i was like we can do some detection out of it right and so i asked him to create a semi-automation
tool so i not i don't like to automate everything i like to you know understand what i'm doing and to have
you know hands on everything happening on the process but there are things that you know like
finding the right payload and putting it writing it again or copy pasting it takes so much time
and so we created like this blind access framework where basically you can put templates and you have
your own config files and you can actually put you know in the request templates it would do some
smart match and replace to actually put the right payload and so you do not need to know the payload
by heart just create your template and you go for it and this tool is highly modulable and right now
we are giving it to a few uh backhunters to
to test it and see like what people need out of it one feature that i really would like to to do is
that uh creating data flows like request flows but better said uh where for instance there is blind
exercise that may happen in the checkout right and that's something it's really hard to automate yeah
and what i want to do is like from the login up to the checkout you could record all the the requests
right and so replay all the requests yeah and like logging in adding a product going to check out and then
but you modify one request at the time and um if the request is not uh like since you record the
request and response if the response is not expected you drop the entire flow and you start from the
beginning with a new request almost like fuzzing almost like fuzzing but in a way that you keep
the logic of you know adding a product in your cart and then from the car i guess you are paying i should
have said more like symbolic execution where it's like you have a certain flow and you say it has to
meet all of this specific criteria and if so this is a success case exactly so i'm a little bit uh curious
how does that that flow correlate to blind xss are you trying to get the application into different
states where you think that it may trigger some sort of uh appearance in a log log on an admin panel or
something like that or there was a research for some from someone that was really interesting about
um using log4j uh like trying to trigger log4j uh payloads in but in a real weird situation and
basically like the research was about doing error based uh requests so you will trigger a lot of
requests you will try to you know get banned your ip band stuff like that and put you know beacons in
the headers stuff like that everything that the app shouldn't do you try to do it in order to generate
a log and those kind of flows i'm saying like like an incident or something like that like someone look
at this guy he's doing something weird and then that exactly and that will trigger the the flow
for instance uh you have a checkout page and you put a product imagine and maybe imagine that the api
you can change the product name or the cart name and that's that you know you need to test those kind
of thing but it takes so much time to test all the different possibilities that my dream will be to
have those data flow and when you say possibilities do you mean it because this is going back to what you
were saying earlier about a payload are you talking about like payload like like using a polyglot
payload for like where it will trigger on the admin side or are you talking about at the entry point
like the parameter that that's okay so you're saying okay you know log in add a product um go to the
cart uh change the cart name so that the you know submit the order exactly and then the payload's in
the cart name and then exactly go back do it again and then this time we do it in the notes
shipping the order knows the shipping yeah exactly gotcha very cool yeah that would be really cool
automated flow yeah uh we're still working on that uh it's a lot of work and especially even yeah
yeah sessions make that very difficult it's interesting because um one i'm a little ashamed
to admit this but i haven't i didn't even use nuclei or like httpx or anything until like a couple weeks
ago and um i i think one of the things that really pushed me over the edge to start doing that is that i
like you did basically entirely manual testing for a very long time i i would focus on specific things i
would see weird behavior and i would chase that down and i came to a point where i realized like
i'm i need to do more breadth but it doesn't have to be necessarily in depth like if i just want to
identify oh this host is online i don't have to go open 15 tabs i can just run a tool that does that
automatically and make my life a little bit easier and then maybe i can do some manual testing to figure
it out or i can take a polyglot payload or or you know a tool like what you're writing and use that to
even go one step further and narrow down my scope even more well yeah well go ahead yeah what's
interesting about automation is that there is in my opinion three ways of doing backbring team you
yeah you have full manual so you just check the request one by one this is exactly what i was
gonna say good good there is full automation uh where you basically trust your servers and computers to do
everything and there is like where i kind of see it uh semi-automation yeah so my problem with automation
is that it's not becoming like about getting creative view of ability understanding your scope it's about
doing a race uh against all the people that does automation right you do not need to have the most
accurate results you need to be the first one right right uh for instance the subdomain takeover scene
is really like that right now so if someone has a specific automation and someone maybe
know how to code in go or ross this person will get the subdomain first right right and that's not
in the way that i like to do hacking but you can be really good at it right right there is manual
testing where it's really long you need to go thorough you you made a tweet about you know knowing
the application till you get sick of it yes yes and i'm sick of getting sick of applications yes yes 100
yeah and because it's such a grind like i think exactly we've talked about this a lot like you have
to get intimate with the application right gotta get intimate with it but that i mean some applications
the amount of features the amount of depth there is to an application that can take weeks maybe even
months to fully understand every little piece every i mean i'm thinking about like it's a great example
where i mean such a huge complicated application where yeah it can take so long to get a full grasp of how
does this thing work how do these systems connect together and if you aren't using tools to your
advantage to sort of take you know jump up five stairs up or whatever right like you just have to
kind of use some of the tools that are out there because even though it might feel like oh you know
i really want to just do this manually i don't want to you know let the tools tell me what to do
you know it's really worth it it's worth your time and it's worth the amount of effort and energy that
you're going to spend you know days weeks whatever it would to learn that application just to you know
get one step ahead because you know the subdomain uh takeover is a great example i know tons of people
who do automation for that kind of stuff and that's not really what my focus is right like i understand
like yeah you could maybe code up a really fast example but you're starting at the beginning compared
to all these people who've been automating for a very long time they're already multiple steps ahead
and instead you could focus on something that is deeper that the automation is not necessarily going
to pick up but you can get there by taking a couple shortcuts right that's true learn some of the
the you know nuance to that application without having to go through the whole manual process yeah
and from the very beginning uh i think about it kind of like learning a language right this is great
you've been learning japanese and it's like you know uh it's it's instead of you know learning one
word at a time and then we're learning two thousand words and being like okay now i'm gonna try and
say hello my name is joel like yeah it's like learn hello my name right hello my name is the pieces
that actually help you in your daily life that's like a really good example with japanese is that
instead of understanding like every word uh i'm what i'm trying to do is actually say sentences that i
will use during my trip like for instance uh i want this thing uh kureo kudasai like and that's
it like i do not need to know everything but he's been learning japanese for like four days
very very very fast yeah like like he picked it up so fast oh yeah i i i can't have a discussion
that's my goal in two weeks you know uh but but but yeah like this is a good example for instance uh
you also like with semi-automation you need to know what is worth automating yeah for instance uh
yesterday we were looking uh with justin um on google and google has a lot of proprietary protocols
and there is it worth automating at one point we were asking this question this application we
well we want i asked you this exactly i was like lupin is this you know we we read a great write-up on
essentially how it works which will which will link yeah and uh and we're like okay so do we want to
build a you know essentially a burp extension surrounding uh making this much easier to test
or do we want to just look at look at you know take our knowledge of the protocol and essentially just
every single time uh burn that additional mental cycles to you know translate in our brain to you
know what we're seeing and and that was a discussion we had and i think that's a really important
discussion to have for automation um yesterday we landed on building the automation because we uh that
that those mental cycles uh really inhibit uh creativity and hacking and this is something we talk
about on the podcast a lot but anytime you can reduce friction to to testing um you know you want to
be able to ideally in an ideal world you want to be able to have an idea oh what if i did this yeah
and then test that immediately yeah yeah and and that's what we're kind of shooting for with that
so yeah it's it's exciting for sure what's really interesting about this specific application and why
we went on the automation route of it is because this application use this google proprietary protocol
called batch execute to doing rpcs code but this is not the only application that use this protocol right
and so basically if we build automation with that specific app in example like for instance you
went like for manual testing and i went from automating what he learned from the manual testing
and so if we have a good proof of concept with that application every other google application using
that protocol we will we be able to assess it faster and to understand it better right and so that's
what was the reason why we're coming for you google and that was the reason why the automation made sense
but at the same time we didn't went on the route of okay we're going to get all the requests from the
javascript and then play it and fast them it's just like getting all the requests and having like a
template of what to send and then we can do manual testing yeah so we save hours of reverse engineering the
javascript to for concentrating only on the creativity part yes not the searching but on the hey is a
uh pollution on that uh parameter uh what if i put this id here you know that kind of stuff yeah and and
i want to say as well it it just before we jump into something else but the you it's it's very tempting
to think about it like a math equation like okay um am i going to save brain sort of cpu cycles
by by you know spending let's say three hours up front to build the automation right uh is that
going to save me three hours worth of time and i i thought about it like that for a while but then
i realized this is really not uh the best way to think about it because precisely we're not catching
and quantifying that whole piece of like how much it's inhibiting our creativity or inhibiting our our
attack vector formulation to constantly be having to all right now i gotta your own code this and i gotta
stick this in this little json blob and uh i gotta fix the escaping and bloody bloody blah and so you
know uh i think oftentimes like that especially when you're committing to a target for a longer
period of time um even if you think you won't necessarily get that time back you will get roi
on that because your brain will work more efficiently in that environment that's true yeah 100 i've also
done some hacking on google uh maybe like a month ago and i ran into a very very similar situation where
um just like the entry point to hacking it can be very difficult because of these specific protocols
and these weird formats that they use and so it's not so much that you're building out like a tool
that's going to automate the entire thing yeah but it's really almost just like a helper script right
it's like in the same way that burp has a pretty tab and a raw tab right you can just make it format it
for you you can make it decode that for you or make it readable for you so that when you hover over the
request or when you're scrolling through you can identify and you can pattern match manually
significantly faster and easier than you would that's right by doing it over and over again
manually and be like hold on where's that uh weird bite that i'm looking for okay there's the there's
the type and you know just that is very mentally draining and it's just like having you know like
sometimes i'll do it with python i'll just write like a little function or a script or something
and i'll have it in my terminal and i'll just i'll just have it like read from my clipboard or
something to do it automatically and that's so much easier than than like writing an entire piece
of tooling definitely yeah actually joel i i steal it from you because i actually want you to talk
about that a little bit because that's like one of the coolest things that i've seen about your
hacking methodology so essentially please expand but he's got a set of functions that he's built over
time and then you essentially just open up the python terminal it reads from the clipboard and then you
you can kind of chain together these automations right yeah 100 i have a little module i call pyhack
and basically whenever i i use ipython as my terminal okay and essentially i'll just import
this file and it has a bunch of little they're like aliases like bash aliases for me but they're
more complex and it's easier for me to write in python than it is in bash and it'll do stuff like url
decode or slash escape like a common scenario is i'll copy something that has slash n's in it right and
i want to see it without i want to see them literally as slash and so i have a just a little helper
function that takes them decodes them and prints it out manually and just make it like so much easier um
html decoding uh hex hex encoding hex decode like and just little tiny helper things things to group
stuff these are the types of like very little you know nuance that makes it so much easier and you
have them for everything yeah all sorts of things yeah like like every single time i'm like okay joel's
gonna have to code something like because because we we pair hack you know from time to time so like
uh you know i see your screen you know when you do this and i'm like all right this time he's gonna
have to do like some like dot replace or something like that no every single time you've got a function
for it yes yeah yeah on that on that note on the pair hacking i was sitting in front of them uh at
the paypal event and it's just the best thing ever to watch them both of them all day on one single
problem oh my god i haven't seen that many years of muscular faces over the day like both of them were
like oh oh why why it's like i think i think i figured out oh no yes no that was just so funny but
you guys really complete one another and i i i think it really works well for you yeah i think pair
hacking works specifically well for for joel and i like uh i think i think uh i like to say it i i point
joel you know at the thing like joel brain power that you know like to be honest i think that like
every person's like doing by meeting needs a uh pair hacker uh with them and that's what we've seen
in the top uh bug bounty hunter community like if you see uh france frozen matthias carlson yep if you
see jonathan there's sean yeah and like everyone is uh like there is one hacker yeah always with you
100 yeah i mean it's like so we've always said like two brains are better than one and this doesn't have
to be an in-person thing i think one of the advantages of being in person is that you can feed off of each
other like we don't even like there'll be things that we just don't even like talk like we'll just
be like looking at the same thing and we'll be picking up things at the same pace and i'll be like
oh did you see that and you'll be like yeah yeah that's really interesting and it's like what's that
right but it's like we're we're just sort of on that level where we're able to sort of go and
when you get to that point your efficiency is literally 2x or more because you have two people
two two perspectives like he has seen things that i haven't seen i've seen things that he hasn't seen
i know techniques that he doesn't know he knows techniques that i don't know you've got little
scripts that can encode things faster and i can't right and he knows like he's like oh just here do this
you know i found it like just run this thing and i'm like what i don't even know how this works
whatever i'll just run it yeah like last time in vegas i met matthias carson and we were talking
about that and he told me what you need to do is to find someone with the same technical skill as
you yes uh but at the same time that can complete you like you do not need a mentor you need some
someone to grow with you right and like that that's something that a lot of beginners uh
uh have trouble with is that oh i need someone to learn from and that's not the fact like you
need someone to learn with yes in order to grow up together and i think that's the best best part of
hacking when you can just you know critical things right right hey honestly honestly one of the most
amazing things that i see especially with like mentor relationships it's not always like mentors so
many times i'll be mentoring like someone who's new to bug bounty and they will ask
what might seem as a simple question but i'm like why haven't i ever thought about that like why what
like i just made like some sort of assumption because i would you know i was i'm more advanced
and i i just like was like oh it's definitely gonna behave this way and the beginner will be like
is it gonna behave that way and i'm like actually is it right like i should probably look and check and
that again it's like you are learning with them you're growing together it's not just like oh let me teach
you this right like some of it is that but it's also you have to feed off of each other and be
willing to to open and change your perspective and learn new techniques yeah that's actually how
i learned um hacking like uh i went on discords or like beginner discords because i was a beginner at
the time and all the questions that the beginners i was trying to answer them but not like i was doing
the rtfm for them and i was like but i was like all the questions that they have is question that i
will have and if i can answer them right now when i will confront it it will be easier for me that's
great yeah and i think that's like if you do not have anyone uh to to learn with it's great to do it
that way because you have like so much question from all over the people like you know uh getting access
to attack surface that you do not have like for instance hey what is this protocol hey what is
this can you hack it and like i i just went like grinding for like three four months and by the end
of the day you get actually like a good skills about what an attack surface is and when you are going on
bug bounty hunting it's easier for you and you feel safer yeah so much of this goes back to like when i try
and describe how you should be picking up hacking it's really you should be in the beginning question
everything right like yeah what is http what what does this get slash http slash one point what does
this mean like how what is this structure why does it look this way how does it behave how does it get
interpreted when i when i click a button what's happening oh man and like just breaking that down
and understanding it at a like a fundamental level builds those core building blocks that you can then
use forever right just like what you said like building out a tooling that will make your life
easier when you're testing some specific protocol it just sets the ground floor so that you can go up
from there and you have a solid foundation that um that that that happened to me uh when i was trying to
use a bypass for ssrf and uh basically i went you know on the cheat sheet and uh and took like uh a octal
uh bypass like basically the ips in auto format and you put it and i was like what is this format and so
i went directly at the source the corvid the rfc of ip and it started at 6 pm and ended up at 5 am
the freaking rabbit hole of what the heck is an ip but by the end of the day it helped me so much to
bypass uh stuff because an ip can be so many things it just needs to be a 32-bit integer but they do not
specify how like if it's an extra decimal in octal uh like the point that the four dots uh format is just
you know a convention but actually you every um caller needs to interpret uh all the different kind of
formats which is insane and uh when you know that you know how to actually bypass uh those kind of
absolutely and and those sort of those sort of tricks are are the only you know you're gonna find
those tricks by diving deep and getting and getting far into those yeah we had a thread uh really
recently like you went you you just gave me uh a domain and said oh there's an xss on it just try to
find it and like one hour later it was like oh there was a really cool challenge but we didn't
have like the we didn't have the same answer to that challenge and like we looked at it and like
why your payload works yeah and actually created a lot of debates on twitter yeah i actually saw
something like this recently somebody made a made a great twitter post we'll have to find it i don't
remember who it was but they they showed an example of a command injection yeah where you could
encode the command in this really really weird yeah it was like there was like backslashes before
each letter and it's like all sorts of weird things i was like i looked at it was like how how
the heck does this even work yeah and i actually bookmarked it because i need to go back later and
i need to figure out how it works and it's one of those things where you're like if you can figure
out fundamentally how this works the the fundamental parts of why it's working and what's going on
there apply in other scenarios you don't have to do it exactly like the exact same way but you can
use those pieces together to build it to build it and i think this is a great transition because
you you made a video recently about uuid v1 and want to talk about like deep dive and like
understanding like weird nuance in something that seems very typical uuid v1 versus uuid v2 3 4.
it's it's a lot of nuance in there so can you talk a little bit about that yeah definitely um so i i was
hacking with snorlax like uh you know the french team we really hack a lot together and uh this target we
really hammered it for uh months and months right and we knew everything and uh this target had
everything in scope so even third parties and uh acquisitions and so we were on this new acquisition
that wasn't that wasn't explicitly in scope and um he was like oh that's weird like uh the password
reset is on another domain and he just linked it to me and i was like wait a minute that's a uid v1
and why did that trigger is because i don't know why and i don't know how but for i think it was
because i was programming something that needed uid i was like what's the difference between v4 and v1
right uh actually it's because at mano mano we were fixing a third party stuff that had collision with
v4 and i was like what's the difference with uid anyway and i found this blog post from verse sprites
team uh actually talking about uid v1 being generated on on timestamps and i was like that doesn't seem
secure and it doesn't like just use timestamps it also used the mac address and the clock id of the
machine so the mac address is basically the mac address and xsd small format so if the same machine
generate two uids it will say the same the clock id is the same it's a value that is set at the creation of
a machine like the first boot and it will always stay the same so you actually have like two chunks
of the uid that always stay the same and the last chunks are the version so if it's uh uid v1 you
will see that the third chunk the first number will be the version so it's one two three four five it's
the first first thing i look at whenever i see uid is like third octet first character and if it's a
four i go and if it's a one i go yeah exactly and so uh and when you see one you know that it's generated
on timestamps right and so then you see that the the third chunk is actually the high and then you have
the mid and the low and i don't know exactly why they're called like that but when you are put together
like uh you you just concatenate them it's it's doing an extra decimal value and this this exciting
similar value uh when you put it in decimal give you a time step in the julian calendar so i went on
the internet searching why the julian calendar and i didn't find the reason like why the heck would you
use that in the calendar use epoch like normal people you know and and then you can you know do some
basic math i'm really bad at math so of course those have to be basic and to to put it in the
epoch timestamp and you get the date with a normal converter and like you you you can have like some
kind of disclosure of when this idea has been generated right and now they use uidv1 for the
password reset and uidv1 since you can know the time that have been generated and you can reconstruct
them really easily because it's just you know uh trying to uh to plus one in the x decimal values
uh you can actually do something called the sandwich attack so basically you generate um
a password reset for the attacker then you generate one uh for your victim and again for the attacker and
the attacker pile is the layer of bread and the victim is like the ham the garniture everything and
you basically sandwiched the reset token of your victim between your two uh tokens yes and someone
asked me why do you need the other layer like you can just put the first one and the the victim one and
you can just brute force until you have the victim yeah it's just to give you um a sense about if your
script is working like if you have a balance over yeah if you go over that value it means that you didn't
find the id right right and so there is another thing going on right so that's why it's better to
sandwich yeah that's awesome so much of this reminds me of ctfs i i i ctf like security ctfs do such a
good job with these weird these weird things stuff like you one is a great example where there's weird
nuance to how things that might seem intuitive work and that makes it perfect for a ctf where it'll be like
hey look at this piece of code this looks completely normal but what's wrong with it yeah right and you
have to go wait a second yeah what is wrong with this oh it's uidv1 and why is that vulnerable oh
because you can you know you can use timestamps and you can predict the next the next value and so
forth and having that type of training um even though it's not like a bug bounty it's very very
related and it builds some of that like fundamental knowledge and the the understanding of those weird
technologies which honestly they're weird but they're used in the real world so often that it's
not like a useless thing to know it's it's a very very useful powerful piece of thing to learn
and also yeah i was so i was just gonna ask about that like um when when you're when you're
there was a really cool comment on on the the twitter post yeah for that and essentially it was
saying um using the new smashing the state stuff yeah i've seen the comments yeah so okay well we'll say
for those that are listening i haven't seen it uh one of the comments on twitter said using the smashing
the state um research that james kettle recently released um you should be able to get sub one
millisecond um uh you know almost collisions with your requests right they can be processed within
the same millisecond uh assuming that that process is generating a uuid v1 um uuid do you know if they
will collide or how how will that work do you know um so uh uuid v1 uh are on the nanoseconds uh okay so no
never james get do your and make it faster james it might collide but like i i i i don't really know the
probability of that uh but i think that was a really interesting comment because um that's basically
i've seen like the article from james peddle about uh so you want to be a security researcher and he
says you need to go uh hunt for forgotten knowledge so stuff that other people missed like for many many
years for instance dns rebinding 2005 everyone was using dns rebinding and then it got lost and someone
was like what if it works on the client side like of browsers and like that's reminding that yeah
that makes me remember something yeah hunt for forget that name in years and try to create diversity
from this forgotten knowledge so basically uh this applied the logic of a vulnerability to other type
of technologies and stuff like that that dns rebinding is a prime example of that and then uh you have
to get outside of the comfort zone your own comfort zone is the same as many other people and so if
you get outside your comfort zone you will be on untouched territory and this kind of comments about
hey can we take this research and this other research and smash them together go for it no idea
stupid until proven wrong and so i i thought that this comment was so great uh and uh kudos to
the person that thought about it totally totally agree with that um yeah always looking for those
sort of opportunities to combine those two pieces together and generate something new um so i we're
we're getting close to we're getting close to that what time is it actually 10 45 okay we need to wrap
up soon but i did want to ask um one last thing regarding your you know experiences at live hacking events
um like you said we we all have you know these collab people that we collaborate with that help uh and that
you know we kind of complete right and complete us um so you collaborate uh often with the the french
team yeah can you talk a little bit about the dynamics and what kind of lessons you've learned
from that collaboration yeah um the french team is uh it's super great uh we didn't have a better name
that just the french team so the croissant you know there and uh croissant man the baguette um yeah
the bugette the bugger dude that's it that's it okay i'm going to bring some with them that that'll be
great yeah and um yeah we have an interesting i'm actually really proud of that
that that you should you should be oh man the royalties are going to be expensive
um it's actually really great because on every live hacking event we always manage to invite one of
the team and what's interesting is that um the team is composed like of five people so we have
doomer zax that uh they both work uh the busy busy hunt they created the company uh we have snorlax
who is an amazing hunter uh there is a bonsoir day who is an upcomer but like he did some amazing
job with open sea every single yeah yeah yeah crit after crit right yeah and uh there is me and
again which speaks for itself and uh you know me of course and needless to say i'm saying that because
we are so different in our ways to hunt uh for instance zax is is really methodological about the way
like he does he does everything on a checklist like i'm going to check that then that then that
doomer is really good at spreading and finding attack surfaces snorlax is really good about uh you
know finding specific vulnerabilities and also finding some weird stuff and i'm i think i'm good about uh
finding new research and so what happened is that snorlax and i and i it's like a counter-strike uh esports
team like we we are with not like the pivot like we are going on another direction while they are
hunting or the main scope right and we are like doing some crazy weird stuff and once we find
something interesting we give it to them to uh first to do more to find an attack surface and to spread
this vulnerability everywhere and then to uh zax to add to the checklist of things to to check and
anything this reminds me of i mean shoves especially is a great example because his recon game is insane
and he'll just find like 15 different like weird things and be like hey man i have this weird thing
like do you want to go check it out i'm like yeah yeah and just like how justin was saying oh i'll
like point joel in the right direction it's very much so like that where like that you'll find a lead
and you'll be like i think we can get this but like let me let you take a crack at it because i know you
can do it shoves is like you get a weird thing you get a weird thing you're gonna hit it
oh probably i love it uh but but yeah like um the way the dynamics works we are everyone each one of
us have their own role and the counter strikes team is amazing because it is like it's the a good example
because you have the guys doing the entry points you have the other one doing the support and you have
like the lurkers that are going to another direction and that's basically what we're trying to apply
within the team we do not want to be on you know all looking at the same thing we want to
overlap yeah overlapping and um for instance at the epic games event at the beginning of the year
um we were all looking at different stuff and there was like this moment where hey i got this
thing working do you think that on your scope it will work and we spread it dash it everywhere and
it works everywhere and that's the dynamic like we we want to do and we do not any overlap so that
works great and also we are like really great friends and we love to yeah you know when we're hunting
10 days in a row not sleeping the the the last day we have mental breakdown and just at 2am not
managing to write a report and like just someone breathing to the microphone makes us laugh for
hours and hours and well like this is like the greatest thing ever about like being with your
friends and not just you know working yeah no i i it's definitely it's definitely an amazing experience
and i want to i want to talk you know because last last time maybe it was last episode or the episode
before i talked a little bit about some of the difficulties of collaboration just to be clear
i am not you know against i'm not anti-collaboration i just think that there are some challenges and it
seems like you and and some of the other people that have you know been doing collaboration
successfully consistently have really ironed out those details and i think that's that's awesome
and if you do it in a way that's intentional and aligns with everyone's goals then it rocks and i
experienced that as well so yeah it's uh it's great to see you you doing that what what i like with
collaboration like i like to do for instance when i'm not collaborating with the french team is that
for the beginning i said i say like how do you want to collaborate how do you want to split and
before even finding vulnerabilities so use everything straight and what i like to do is even if the other
person does not find anything but i know that they're actively searching i want to still give them 50
of of the report because i know that if i continue collaborating with that person and that if i trust
the person yeah i they they will do the same thing for me and we're going to balance out burnties
over the time yeah and that's you know how you create real bond and friendship it's not about
money it's about you know having human interaction trust another and trust exactly awesome well that was
i think that's like a perfect note to end it on i mean yeah is there anything you want to shout out
obviously your company what is it l and h or l n h looping and arms l i a n d h dot take for the
website i just want to say thank you guys for everything you've been doing on the podcast it's
just amazing all the debates that is created like the one about programs innovation i love it that's what
we needed in the community so shout out to you guys for everything you've been doing yeah well thank
you for being on we really appreciate it and um yeah that's the pod right
you